j'espère que ça va bien chez vous si ça
se passe pas trop mal ça se met en place
Adecco à avoir posé derrière qui va
arriver là vous allez voir ça va être
sympa mais ça ça arrivera dans quelques
temps aujourd'hui on est là pour parler
ici on parle du LG c'est la version et
ce truc intéressant pourquoi parce qu'on
a un écran 17 pouces un point
extrêmement c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui réalisé en partenariat avec LG pour
vous présenter vous allez voir qu'elle
est très surprenant qu'elle peut être
fait pour tout le monde mais peut-être
est-elle faite pour vous et ça c'est
intéressant
regardez-moi ça comme c'est mignon LG g
alors ça écrit s'il peut pas trompé j'ai
RAM grave
comme ça
je
sais pas si vous avez
vu
ça pèse vraiment
je prends cette petite boîte et voilà
c'est
vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment vraiment
bien autant
il y a deux trois petits points de
détails que j'ai un tout petit peu moins
c'est qu'en fait je suis habitué à voir
si vous voulez aujourd'hui un trackpad
qui vient vraiment le lait chez le bord
donc lorsque je viens ici il y a des
fois je viens un petit peu me tape sur
le côté c'est vraiment du point de
détail à côté de ça ce que je vais aimer
et si c'est le capteur d'empreinte
digitale qui est situé juste la sur la
touche et si je pose mon doigt ça
déverrouille et tout de suite
extrêmement rapidement bonjour Windows
ça c'est cool et sur Windows 11 natif
Windows 11 famille c'est vachement bien
je vous invite à ma vidéo sur Windows si
vous l'avez pas vu ça c'est super
intéressant et quelque part par là
quelque part aller jeter un œil dessus
donc très grand clavier rétroéclairé on
peut venir moduler la lumière du clavier
on a tout ce qu'il faut si vous voulez
utiliser votre petit nid et bien vous
pouvez bras c'est extrêmement complet et
très très cool ici ensuite vous avez un
grand écran alors désolé pour les
reflets sur le dessus vous avez un grand
écran de 17 pouces avec des bars sur
c'est plutôt pas mal aussi regarder des
petits bord sur le côté on va retrouver
des petits bord sur le haut on va
retrouver une petite webcam c'est du HD
720p pour les micros pour parler sur la
conférence en ce que vous voulez appeler
votre part à votre grand-mère ou la
votre patron pour les conférences en
famille ou trop fusionnelle sans
problème ça ça marche bien on a un écran
regarder je vous remets c'est du
lapin coucou c'est moi avec l'écran
c'est du 17 pouces LCD
connaissez aussi les trois
dixièmes le vous avez en fait 11
pourcents de toute façon plus par
rapport à la place de c'est plutôt pas
mal l'écran il est très très grand dit
c'est tout ça je sais pas si vous
travaillez dans 17 mois je travaille sur
un 16 pouces et là je dois vous avouer
que je trouve ça hyper hyper hyper hyper
confort et ça ça me plaît bien réussi
l'écran tactile il faut le savoir
faut-il
prendre une très très grosse machine
c'est une très très belle machine est
très légère vraiment on a un écran qui
est 99 % ça une résolution alors j'ai
noté terme
wqxga
2560 de
1560 par 1600 pixels et on va essayer
jusqu'à 310 alors écran plus lumineux en
plein jour bien évidemment nous pour
toute la productivité familiales pour
l'utilité dans un bureau ou dans une
bagnole si on est en déplacement ça le
fera en déplacement parce que très léger
ça se pratique une fois de plus alors
pour apporter ici en terme de légèreté
et bien on a complètement en magnésium
ça s'est plutôt bien et en plus si on a
une certification militaire
certification militaire américaine alors
qu'est-ce que ça vous raconte tout ça il
est résistant au choc compression
température température à la poussière
au vibration et également au brouillard
salin rien donc en fait on va éviter de
le prendre dans la bouche parce que
c'est pas fait pour ça et pour tout ce
qui va dire et et bien usage domestique
qui bouge un petit peu on aura PSO luman
aucun problème au truc qui va
m'intéresser qui sont quand même très
complète là vous avez dû HDMI là vous
avez de
4 ans alors qu'est-ce que c'est
un disque dur externe
très très vite donc ça c'est vachement
bien avoir des livres et vous allez
venir utiliser ces prises là pour venir
le recharger alors pour recharger vous
avez un bloc de charge 65 fois qui est
bien évidemment fourni avec mon sang
quoi ça serait la blague petit bloc 65
watts signer LG bien évidemment et comme
je disais on est ici en USB c'est donc
ça c'est aussi extrêmement pratique mais
ça ne s'arrête pas là c'est très
compliqué parce que j'aime bien
évidemment une petite prise jack pour
écouter de la musique avec un
micro
et ça c'est plutôt sympa
donc si vous voulez venir
vous pouvez faire attention
recommandé pour faire du montage du tout
petit montage si vous le souhaitez vous
avez en plus il y
a 4 x on peut avoir soit 8 x 32 ma
version CIC
16512 giga de stockage commence aussi
jusqu'à je vous recommande pas combien
de temps pour venir faire du montage je
vous recommande très clairement pour la
productivité vous avez un grand écran
donc un vrai confort pour venir
travailler sur le tableur pour venir à
faire de la saisie du traitement de
texte tout ce que vous voulez la
productivité ça ira parfaitement bien
alors j'ai bien travaillé petite pause
vous mettez un petit film une petite
série sur un écran de 17 pouces vous
croyez au cinéma 13 quelque chose près
de chez vous avez des haut-parleurs vous
avez des haut-parleurs c'est du 2 x 2
watts avec Tecno dps ultra et si vous
voulez brancher un casque sans fil
de fer vous avez
aussi j'ai vraiment mis en avant et si
vous avez une batterie de
loin alors
bien évidemment ce n'est pas une machine
à faire du montage vidéo quoi qu'on peut
en faire un tout petit peu on va se
calmer là tu n'es pas une machine pour
faire du gaming du gaming pousser du
coup
pourquoi pas un petit peu trop lourd
à la connexion wifi
aucun problème
et bien
on est
aussi
alors
au maximum
ça ça me conviendra aussi relativement
bien comme je les ai j'ai une petite
webcam en 720p alors 720p ça va pas
est-ce qu'il va y avoir mieux en terme
de définition mais je dirais combien
faire des appels avec tatie ou alors
avec le patron c'est très très bien
comme je l'ai sur un Windows 11 famille
Windows 11 j'en ai parlé à votre menu
Démarrer au centre vos applications
préférées ici puis toutes vos
applications qui sont installés
directement la des petits raccourci
sympathique sur le côté vous avez vos
notifications qui sont planqués juste
ici vous avez votre venue ici avec
notamment la luminosité pouvez venir
régler très facilement et la poussa font
310 ans c'est pas tout le plus lumineux
mais il fait plus propre intérieur ça
ira très très bien avec Cécilia votre
wifi bluetooth le mode avion si vous
souhaitez l'économiseur de batterie
l'assistant concentration sur Windows 11
ans qui est complète à la question
pourquoi est-ce que je devrais venir me
positionner sur ce LG g 17 pouces et
bien en fait il y a plusieurs raisons
déjà on va venir se positionner sur
cette machine si on cherche un très
grand écran il existe en 14 pouces et en
16 pouces ça c'est plus grand le 17
pouces mais ce qui me bloque une fois de
plus la voir un très grand écran dans un
format
active mon grand ou petit pois
extrêmement léger donc si vous êtes
nomade et vous avez des besoins de
productivité sur LG g 17 pouces est
vraiment fait pour vous qu'on a
suffisamment de performance en Intel
Core i7 ira parfaitement bien on a
beaucoup de confort au niveau de la
frappe l'autonomie c'est aussi un point
fort de cette bécane et puis le fait que
vous ayez beaucoup de connectique
convient branché tout ce que vous voulez
que c'est un format qui me plaît bien et
que je trouve que c'est différent par
rapport à ce que j'ai pu retrouver sur
l'ensemble du marché gratuit gratuit et
payant d'ailleurs si elle vous intéresse
un lien dans la description
et une fois de plus ce qui me pousse un
paquet mais à ce point-là vous la prenez
elle est tellement légère que pourrait
me le fait que je passe des heures à
faire de la muscu alors qu'en fait 1
kilos 35 c'est chouette vous embrasse à
bientôt
[Musique]